you know there's been so much discussion
in public on twitter social media about
whether skinwalker is legit whether it's
worth studying you know the awsap
program was based in part on experiences
that happened there and a concern
whether or not their legitimate national
security
interests there is is it just a mystery
a paranormal mystery or is it a national
security matter well i can tell you this
george and this is the part that really
scares me the most is
gps signals over the ranch and sometimes
it stops at the fence line on the ranch
not just in the region
get jammed and stop working and even are
spoofed to make you make vehicles think
that they're underneath the surface and
not where they are and this could cause
you know airplanes to crash we've
actually had drones uh crash because of
this many times and these aren't just
little cheap drones i'm talking 50 000
drones and that is a dangerous thing if
someone has a technology that can do
that
they could
pick a region and make gps quit
functioning
then you're going to have airplanes that
could crash you could have
automated drones that are going to crash
you could have vehicles that follow gps
systems i mean there's so many things
that that could affect and if it can do
that to gps it can do that to other
things so this is a capability that's
happening of some kind of phenomena
that's happening
that could potentially be a threat
multiple phenomena
and
seemingly intelligent right it's an
intelligence of some sort well if it's
it's if it's not intelligent it's very
uh serendipitously random because it'll
change in a way that is going to be
funnel what your plans are whether a
perfect example is uh uh we'll do
experiments and right when we start to
everything's working fine uh perfectly
with the equipment and right when we're
ready to say okay we're going to take
data now a battery will die or uh a
piece of equipment will will malfunction
or the the memory cards will quit
working
another perfect example is there was one
particular time when i was on the ranch
and we got cameras everywhere and every
time that i stepped in front of one of
these cameras
for 40 something seconds the cameras
went black so there's 40 something
seconds where i'm doing things that
there's no record of because the camera
the camera is still recorded but they
were they blacked out and the audio quit
the same kind of thing happened to nids
the bigelow organization privately that
was there it happened during osap but
they didn't have the kind of cameras
that you guys have what
one great contribution of the tv show is
you're able to demonstrate those small
little things that happen all the time
compasses go crazy batteries die that
nobody has ever been able to prove all
the time i mean uh we'll we have uh
multiple all of us carry conferences we
have composers on our phones and we'll
we'll pull them out when things are
happening and they'll be spinning or
they'll turn it completely wrong
direction and at the same time the cows
will be going crazy uh you know
who i can't explain all that can you
explain the is there the physics of the
hitchhiker effect i know people find
that just too far out you've experienced
it yourself yeah and uh you know
we we're always nervous about talking
about the hitchhiker effect because we
might stimulate it we don't know what
causes it but uh
could there be a physics uh explanation
well if it's uh maybe functioning
through quantum physics there's a
possibility of quantum entanglement that
somehow
whatever describes our
consciousness which is most likely a
quantum phenomena gets entangled uh with
whatever the phenomena is and so
wherever you go you're still connected
to it
and uh that sounds sounds hokey but
we're it's called the quantum
measurement problem a lot of scientists
are are studying it in great detail and
there's been some nobel prize
nominations for the for the topic and so
i think that could be an explanation or
at least uh somewhere in the ballpark
you've had things happen on the ranch
that are creepy i mean
inexplicable call it paranormal but it's
happened it's real right yes very in
fact uh
one it's uh almost uh like what you
would call stigmata that happened to me
uh
uh we had a rabbi out do a a ritual to
that was supposed to summon an opening
to heaven uh which or like a portal is
what you would describe it as down at
homestead 2 and when we did the the
ritual a a thermal uh vortex appeared in
the middle of homestead 2. we got that
on clear data and it was repeatable we
played an audio recording of the chant
back and it happened again well when the
rabbi was there that night he told me uh
off camera he came to me said travis
they said they're going to come to you
tonight
and i'm like what are you talking about
and uh he said well they said they're
gonna they're gonna come see you i said
who's they and the rabbi said well
whoever it is that's here
i thought he was messing with me right
uh well that night
uh i had a dream uh i was in my trailer
that uh my trailer doors were locked and
everything and i i had a sort of a
waking dream that the uh my the trailer
door uh open and my bedroom uh door slid
open and a native walked in to my
bedroom an old a really old native and
he looked at me and he shook his head
and he reached out and he touched me on
the face right there
well and then he then he shook his head
and he walked away and i woke up
startled and i went to the bathroom you
know splash water on my face kind of get
my bearings and when i looked in the
mirror i was bleeding from that spot and
i had a a sore appear there and stayed
there for several days
and and that that was bizarre to me i
can't explain you know you could
probably explain why the bug bit me or
something i've swatted myself but
it didn't look like that it looked like
just like somebody really pressed me
really hard right there you've taken it
home with you haven't you oh uh
i i have seen some things and some
things that my car has started and
stopped itself uh sometimes it'll the
electronics will weird for no reason and
then they'll be fine
i've actually
had that happen once driving out of my
driveway my car just turned itself off
and i just happened to get out because i
was wondering just you know curiosity
and i thought well
if i'm at the ranch i'm gonna get out
start looking around so i got out of the
car and i looked up and there was a an
odd
vortex in the clouds above above my
house
when this happened i can't explain that
i'm just saying those are correlated
events
i don't have any other data to go along
with that but that's a weird piece of
data but when i got back in the car
cranked right up
i guess the correlation would be what
other people have reported i mean a lot
of people who've been at the ranch have
taken things home pretty frightening
things that you know it lasts for a long
time yeah uh i
i've talked with a lot of people who
were there uh during the the bigelow era
and then people that have been out there
now and
many people
have strange things happen at home that
can't be explained they see things
things happen
things fail they have
actual things move in their house that
they don't remember moving them
and so
mine hasn't gotten that bad but i do
have
weird
spooky things happen occasionally is
there overlap of when you're working on
the tv show and then you learn there was
this awesome program that did a big
study and produced a lot of reports
and are you able to go look at that
stuff are you able hey i'm going to go
seek out the guys who did this study so
i can find out if you've got class
you've got security clearances maybe you
could see it yeah and uh
of course i couldn't talk about the
details of any of that but but of course
i mean
anybody with any sense right if they
have access to read information this
weird stuff's happened to them they're
gonna go read the information so i can
tell you that i've asked the people who
know uh and and have been briefed as
much as people know about uh i i think
some of the information though uh mr
bigelow kept to himself yeah and and so
we haven't been privy to that particular
information
you know the needs guys go in
uh bigelow in his organization and
they're drawn by flying saucers ufos
they go in there they're going to study
that but they find all this other stuff
and they really don't have a battle plan
for how to go after it i mean they did
some basic stuff they looked for
geomagnetic anomalies they looked for
psychoactive plants maybe that was
causing hallucinations and when they
started ruling those things out then
they tried to interact with it
is there a battle plan that works for
this i mean you we've talked before
about this you
in essence poke the bear hey let's try
this see what happens i i don't know
what else to do other than uh try a
stimulus and look for a response
because it's so strange it's not your
typical mix this chemical and that
chemical and you get this reaction and
in this case you can mix this chemical
in that chemical and depending on the
day and and and some whimsy you get a
completely different reaction so uh what
i uh i'm trying to do
and with eric and the other guys out
there is we do as many different
experiments that might stimulate
something across all the physical
spectrum of of of stimulus you know
electromagnetic magnetic
gamma rays uh
actual
particle radiation
rockets digging drilling you know you
name it anything we can think of uh
we're trying to see if
we do this this happens hard to predict
though
almost every time something different
happens so
but we have narrowed down the one thing
that seems to happen all the time
and uh actually it's really two things
in in i would say between 80 and 90 of
the of every cases of experiments that
we do
when a phenomena occurs we are measuring
microwaves and we're measuring gamma
rays and so i find that telling what
it's telling me yet i don't understand
but it's happening all up very
frequently the radiation exposure so you
get exposed to radiation you had serious
effects health effects yeah i uh uh they
didn't show the details of it on the
show because you know it's a little bit
eerie a little bit personal too yeah
yeah but it actually caused me some
medical issues i had i saw two or three
different doctors about it uh i'm fine
now um
while i am going to be watching for
future markers of like leukemia or
cancer things but i don't think the dose
was big enough for that but i had the
classic symptoms of radiation sickness
um dark urine
burn marks
and i had some temporary hair loss
and and that it took me
six months almost to a year to get
completely over it
but
i wasn't expecting anything like that
right
and the weirdness was there were people
as close to me as you and they were
wearing radiation
dosimeters as well theirs were fine how
could it
radiation doesn't work that way or at
least as far as we know so while mine
went off and i get the dose
people right next to me didn't and
whatever the source of radiation was it
wasn't there after a while the next day
we had special uh a contractor group
that does this for the navy on new
vehicles come out and look and scour the
ranch for any sources of radiation there
was no source of radiation there but
since then we have measured transient
high uh
doses of radiation in
specific locations and we only have a
handful of of dosimeters and gamma ray
detectors and for us to find it just by
placing one i'll just put one out in the
field see what happens today and it
happened that's really odd the odds of
you hitting that that you know that's
like hitting the game-winning shot every
single time from the other team's
baseline right yeah i don't want to give
away the season that's underway right
now but i mean there are a lot of fairly
dramatic things experiments that you try
that did generate reactions yeah uh we
we actually
we did multiple stimuluses at a time uh
uh multiple stimuli at a time this year
and and sometimes we saw some very
amazing things and got some very amazing
uh footage and data uh simultaneously um
you know the things that have aired uh
we could talk about you know where we
had telescopes that were the databases
inside the telescopes were erased real
time while we were watching them and
they there's no mechanism for that if i
wanted to do that i don't even know how
to reverse engineer that phenomenon uh
and then the same night we had a sphere
fly over the ranch that was
unmistakably an unidentified flying
object not just some aerial phenomena
and so
it was absolutely incredible where does
it come from and where did it go
that's the very interesting question you
know we we had cameras going but
suddenly it's just there and it's flying
on the ranch it does a thing and then
suddenly it's not there so where did it
go where did it come from i don't know
it's part of your interest in the ranch
i mean as a scientist you want to figure
this out is it also fun is it fun
it's uh it's adventurous it's the right
way to say it uh it's it's fun like in
you went through something
like an adventure movie it was scary at
the time but when you look back on it it
was amazing
experience that you got to do